Đi như dịch, hôm nguồ, người ai góc, nó là dữ đi nhạc,
là này của các bất chè một chứng minh bằng thân bệnh.
Chò đến khi...
Phóc lực được phục thi.
Căn cứ rất đều má khoảng trí điều vài, tại vì đi một sâu tâm.
Hành vi được hiện xe là lạc lạc mình vóng xe bị phạp tiền tư.
Tâm chưa đến mười cho nó.
Phó là...
Căn cứ vào đều mắp khoảng 2 điều vài, tại vì đi một sâu tâm.
Không lúc múc vào hiểm chống người đi một tồ xe mại,
khi điều khiến xe tham ra cho thông tin được mộ,
sẽ bị phạp tiền tư.
Bộ chăm, cho đến sản chăm đến đâu.
Nhớ đồ mùa nhạc.
Mò ngày có mơ nữa.
Ô, zó zang.
Số gây sẽ tắt máy.
Căn cứ đi một cái của chi nước vài, tại vì đi một sâu tâm,
xử dụng vòi, gú vâng nền bồ,
đi một tồ mùa tâm, cho mình tập tìt tư.
Tự tham chẳng cho đến mười cho nó.
Nhớ chứ...
Đó là như những nhà những mặt các bạn tè,
sường hay mất phải khi tham ra cho thông.
Tôi khi vòng rằng,
thúc chỉ các bạn chè mặt tất cả mọi người khi tham ra cho thông.
Hãy chấp hình yên các quyền của Pháp Lập về Lập Sao Thông Đúng mộ.
Mà tôi, đã tiếp quý.
Cảm mộ trước trên bỏ, coi vã sá lấy mộ.